we're live from reasons Los Angeles
headquarters outer space is the final
frontier as we all know in a grand arena
for imagining of potential new
advancements for human Liberty not to
mention you in accomplishments now for
the first few decades of human attempts
to get ourselves into space space flight
was largely a monopoly of governments
but we're now moving into a dawning age
of space travel and possible space
living that's accomplished by private
enterprise and I guess here today at
recent EV is one of the men helping make
that happen he is Doug Jones a
co-founder and chief test engineer of
the private space tech company X Corps
where he not only helps design liquid
rocket engines they call him the rocket
Whisperer for his uncanny ability to
troubleshoot rocket propulsion systems
he's also personally test flown X scores
experimental craft like the
rocket-powered aircraft the x-ray sir
he's a real space age Renaissance man
we're very glad to have him here Doug
Jones I hit it so Doug X Cora you
co-founded the company tell us a little
bit about what X Corps was founded to do
what it's done and what you think you're
going to do next when we all got laid
off from rotary rocket in the summer of
nineteen ninety nine and that was a
prior private space tech con right its
basic I did it go under entirely yeah it
died eventually about two years later
and all of us just really hadn't had
enough we knew that it was possible to
make this happen and that if one
organization couldn't make it happen
well maybe we could roll our own and
make it they can do and so basically Dan
nolita and I grabbed Jeff Grayson who
was our boss at rotary rocket and said
you weren't done leading and basically
volunteered him to be the CEO of X Corps
and none of us are regretted it we
certainly none of us knew how much work
would be to get from there to here and
but the journey has been more than worth
it and when you launched what was your
sense of what you wanted to accomplish
and how far the company as well as you
personally and how far have you gotten
along that path
all knew that there was no way that the
government space program was going to
get us personally into space and all of
us had the space bug but that I've had
it since I was five years old and the
only way that we were going to get to go
is if we built the ride ourselves they
would no other way that could happen is
that certainly none of us were
independently wealthy enough to simply
by a ride to go to the space station for
instance and that's a kind of a token
commercialization of a government system
when you're writing on a soy is and what
we really want is something that we
could all go on that and I want to take
my wife up for a wedding anniversary and
a space space space station so the only
way I can actually make that happen is
to build our own ride is that common in
the private space industry that people
are driven by this very personal desire
to get to space themselves yes I've
really seen that you know the Elon Musk
has talked about how he wants to retire
on Mars Jeff Grayson has talked about
how he wants to retire on Mars I want to
ask both of them if they could survive
in a colony of 20 or 30 people in one of
them was Bob Zubrin but pass on that and
everyone else that I know that has
founded these companies you know John
Carmack Dave mast and all of them want
to go themselves and so far those of us
at X Corps are the only founders of the
company that have actually gotten the
ride themselves so now the easy rocket
was an early Xcor accomplishment i
understand that was the first private
rocket-powered aircraft is that correct
as far as we can tell yes that there
were rocket-powered aircraft that were
built by corporations but under
government funding for instance at the
time we did this surely on spec because
at the time back in two thousand i
looked at the long list of static engine
test stands that various small companies
and universities and ammeter
organizations had put together and built
rocket engines and
they hadn't flown a human being on a
rocket right a static is where it's the
engine's going off but it's not
propelling as voted down yeah I'm just
testing the engine yeah and the one
thing that we could see that we could
accomplish quickly with the resources we
had at hand was to demonstrate that we
could fly people routinely and safely on
rocket engines that we had designed and
built and that was what that was really
our breakout in 2001 was when we started
flying the easy rocket and it was you
know we got news coverage we got lots of
press and people in the industry started
taking this more seriously and within a
year after that when Ilan muskan started
SpaceX and they wanted to do their first
testing of their gas generator for the
Merlin engine and they didn't yet have
test facilities they came to us and did
their first testing of their Hardware on
our test equipment so the easy rocket
served its purpose of establishing
basically our calling card that's a
rocket engine development team that
leaves an interesting area there is
amazingly you know for those of us have
been watching this from the beginning a
lot of competition in the field of
private space SpaceX would you mentioned
gets a lot of press Virgin Galactic
within the field is there a sense of
friendly collaboration more competition
how do you guys all interact with each
other it varies you know basically
sometimes based on the personalities of
the principles involved later this week
I'm meeting with some guys from Aston to
discuss to discuss buying some valves
from them to put into our system yeah
and it's what we're all looking forward
to is being able to get around get out
of vertical integration where you build
everything up and down and you're in
your one organization if we can start
buying valves from master right and and
other components from another vendor and
having somebody else use their machine
shop to build some components for us
yeah then that basically you know basic
economics right when you let someone
else do it they're good at it that you
specialize on what you're good at right
so in the beginning there was there was
almost a lack of this division of labor
like you said you were all trying to do
everything from the ground up
and maybe that's changing a bit and as
much as possible and but still there are
times when we have to design a valve to
do a purpose because we can't find any
commercial product that will do a task
that we want and sometimes we can get
existing vendors to design a change to
their existing product to make it better
for us yeah now I know one of your big
projects in the works is the links could
you sort of explain a little bit about
what the links is and what it will do
links which we will have flying later
this year is our third rocket plane we
did the EZ rock at the x-ray sir and now
we're working on the links and the links
mark one is basically our first hack at
it where we get all of our the steep
part of the learning curve out of the
way before we go on to the more
production model mark to the links mark
one is a delta wing twin tail rather
generic looking rocket plane looks a
little bit like the old dinosaur from
the 1960s two-seat vehicle pilot one
participant and suborbital takes off
from the runway on LOX kerosene rocket
engine power flies up to in mark one
peak altitude of around 200,000 feet and
the mark two will go to over 300 28,000
feet 100 kilometers the von Karman line
and the idea is to take participants and
payloads up on a suborbital flight out
of the atmosphere several minutes of
zero-g several minutes above most of the
atmosphere so that you can take a
telescope up and do observations and
where this looks like we'll have a lot
of scientific use to it is to aid
researchers in developing hardware which
would later go on to orbital missions
but get a lot of suborbital experiments
done to help them develop their hardware
and make sure that when they do go to
the expense of an orbital flight it's
more likely to work well if you could
quickly explain the sub sub orbital
versus orbital distinction for
rocket jockeys in our audience in a
orbital system you're actually getting
up completely out of the atmosphere and
getting enough horizontal velocities so
that essentially your some difficult
force holds you up above the earth and
that requires reaching over 5 miles per
second close to eight kilometers per
second total velocity change to get to
that point and it's a very challenging
task it typically takes two or three
stages of a rocket vehicle dropping the
empty ones off on your way up suborbital
is a much simpler task your total
velocity changes is less than a third as
much you're only going up to about 100
kilometers altitude instead of three or
four hundred and you're going to much
lower speeds and when you're coming back
you're at lower speeds so that you don't
have as much heat to deal with on the
re-entry okay and so it's just an up and
return your total flight time is around
half an hour and it's a lower energy
lower expense lower risk mission but
still get you most in the experience
yeah and are you guys already selling
tickets for the passenger part of the
link for the spaceflight participant
part yes we're selling tickets I'm you
know busily grinding away on getting the
hardware biltz I haven't been keeping
track of the sales but we've got a few
hundred so far and reservations for more
and the as the hardware comes together
you know someone who started off as an
enthusiast and has become a professional
it boggles me sometimes that you know
that anybody's doing this and that I'm
part of the team is just every now and
then I have to pinch myself yeah the
links what's its turnaround time going
to be you go up you come down when can
you go back up again we want to be able
to get at least four missions per day
which means you have to be able to turn
it around in under an hour yeah we've
demonstrated turning around previous
vehicle the x-ray sir doing the complete
liquid oxygen kerosene and helium
recharge needed to replenish the
propellants and I think we did it in
about eight and a half minutes that was
with a kind of an IndyCar style approach
to it where we had three teams
approaching the vehicle from three
different directions
and so we had liquid oxygen loading and
helium loading and fuel loading all
going on in separate areas everybody
using their own tools and so if we can
do an indie style turnaround in under 10
minutes we can do a much more relaxed
one in about an hour well and the
re-entry heat aspect of it is you've
solved that problem it's it's modest
most of the aircraft is indeed a
composite structure with you know a
resin and glass or or carbon fiber in it
and it's only at the very nose and
leading edges of the wings and other
surfaces that we need to have an extra
little bit of thermal protection the
peak temperatures under a thousand
degrees Fahrenheit it wouldn't even glow
because we're doing even with the mark
to only a little bit more than Mach 3
memory entries so the peak Tim is
comparable to a high-speed aircraft yeah
now you've yourself have test piloted in
earlier Xcor not piloted I've been the
flight test engineer in the right seat
okay and what this does is it frees up
the pilot and let's see to focus on
flying the aircraft yeah and the the
flight test engineer and the right seat
is watching all the propulsion systems
to make sure those are behaving well and
with an experimental system it helps to
have somebody focused just on that yeah
and did you have your weightless moments
in these test flights with well this was
all subsonic in atmosphere stuff and
rather than weightless moments we had
high G moments where we're doing present
instance of split s and there's nothing
quite like coming around the pattern at
100 knots kicking in the engine
accelerating to 200 then pulling up into
a into a half loop three and a half G's
it kind of gets your attention want to
talk a little bit about the ways your
private business intersects with
government first of all on the
regulatory level like how who who or
what and government has their eyes on
what you guys are doing like FAA have
any say there's a branch of the FAA
called AST it's the associate
administrator for space transportation
and they have the responsibility for
licensing space launches and reentry's
and what you do once you're in orbit is
not of their
concern you kind of want to track
coordinate your traffic with the Air
Force who keeps track of objects in
orbit but we've been talking with the
government since even before X Corps was
founded and that helps you by having a
an ongoing relationship with them you
know meeting them several times a year
we both Jeff and Randall Clegg our
government liaison guy spend a lot of
time going to DC and going to meetings
and pushing back against some of the
less well-thought-out regulations and
helping propose the regulations that we
think would be fair and honest and a
level playing field for everybody
involved are you guys feeling overall
that they are reacting to you and what
you do in a sensible way is there any
big examples of it all those things they
possibly possibly the best example of
them doing a wonderful thing was when
they announced the rule on what a
suborbital spaceflight is and it was at
this face to access conference got about
ten years ago and they said that a
suborbital space craft is rocket-powered
and has thrust greater than lift for the
majority of the powered portion of the
ascent and they got a round of applause
from all these free market people in the
audience because it was such a sensible
rule because aviation generally goes
horizontal right rockets generally go up
yeah they drew the line of 45 degrees I
mean instead of coming up with something
really complicated they came up with a
rule that was based on the dynamics of
what you're doing so even a tail sitting
rocket that only goes up for 10 seconds
and then lands right back where it came
from that's a salora bottle rocket
whereas the EZ rock at our first rocket
plane which had relatively little thrust
and couldn't climb steadily at a 45
degree angle yeah that was still an
airplane okay so it was a sensible
decision and the government is not the
enemy they're just a big blundering
beast that you can kind of nudge in the
right direction is there any sense in
which do you have any kind of client
relationship with the government is NASA
now using companies like you to provide
them services um we've had
contracts with government organizations
before Air Force and ro Navy NASA I
think the largest government contract we
had was back in 06 and 07 when we
developed a large methane engine which
was potentially going to be the main
propulsion for the crew exploration
vehicle and they decided they wanted to
advance the schedule more and realize
they didn't have time to develop
advanced propulsion for it and then went
back to the old tetroxide hydrazine
off-the-shelf stuff but they were very
pleased with the results we got and the
trouble is they just basically ran out
of money because so many other things
were soaking up their budget what does X
score or maybe even you as a person have
a vision of where you want the space
business to be say 10 20 years from now
and its government a necessary part of
that vision in any way um it's a it's a
you have to deal with the government any
time you're doing stuff which is under
regulation but various branches of the
government can also be customers and we
would be just delighted at ten years
from now the space station or whatever
new Bigelow system that and I kind of
envision that once ISS has gotten too
old and needs to be retired some
components of it may have say a large
Bigelow inflatable added and then
basically split it up and salvage it
into various components and Bigelow is
another private space company right
that's dedicated to building essentially
living areas its guests there they
bought the trans hab technology from
NASA and then went on and developed it
further and they have plans for space
stations up to many many times the
volume of the International Space
Station and they will need
transportation for their commercial
customers and that's one of the
potential customers for our later
orbital system which we would be
basically running a taxi service to and
from low Earth orbit and your current
price now is around 95,000 is that right
yes yeah is that is that a necessary
function of just how much it costs in
propulsion to get things to space or do
you see the cost curve on that falling
and why would it the price and cost are
often loosely coupled and when you come
up with a new service you price it as
high as you can to skim off the top of
the market I mean the main purpose the
main function of wealthy people in
society is to serve as the guinea pigs
for the rest of us so that you know we
can extract the maximum value from them
in making them feel that they are you
know truly special people and you know
that's what tourism is all about yeah
and so that there's a certain amount of
cynicism to that but that's the way it
often tends to work out in the real
world there's a whole new level of
regulation come in when you're taking on
paid passengers that's where the
Commercial Space Launch Amendments Act
2004 came in actually Xcor people wrote
the first draft of that and we had
people help push it through Congress and
the idea there is that for spaceflight
participants unlike commercial transport
on aircraft it's not presumed to be
state safe for the participant instead
it's an informed consent regime which is
more like going skydiving yeah or
mountain climbing where you have to sign
a consent form that says yes I know this
is unnecessary you know there's I'm not
trying to get from point A to point B by
taking this rocket flight it's an
excursion it's an adventure and so the
rules for that are much less stringent
than when you're trying to take grandma
we're off to see the grandchildren sure
Doug really take some questions from our
online audience now if you don't mind
first one is from Edward Durie via
Facebook who asks in what ways do you
envision private space travel becoming
profitable well quite simply by keeping
our costs including amortization of our
development below the price that we're
charging per seat and we chose the
95,000 dollar price with with careful
thought knowing that we should be able
to recoup all of our development costs
and make a tidy profit at that price
point and still be able to engage in a
price war with the competition
the market when the market grows we want
to get a larger share of it yeah
everyone also wants to know and I'm
going to interpret this for him a little
bit if space privateers are going to be
the leif erickson's of the future and I
think what he meant by that is it in a
sense do you see permanent human living
in space in the next 10 20 years we
almost have permanent living in space
now you know we have we've had crews on
ISS for more than a decade now you know
the population count up there you know
has averaged about three over the last
decade has finally gotten back up to six
and with in the future there'll be more
people if be more like Antarctica that
you rarely get people living there
living their lives out having children
there and so on it's still part of the
economic sphere of the world or offshore
oil well platforms where you don't get
people living their entire lives there
but doing professional work there for
for companies that turn a profit sure
even farther afield from that Edward via
Twitter he wants to know realistically
speaking when can we expect tourism to
Mars even just fly buys the the recent
proposal for the mars flyby was really
quite impressive I've met you know
several of the people involved in that
and there's no reason to think they
can't get it done it's a it's a
straightforward enough mission they've
people have done you know closed life
support systems for that long it's you
know it's based on maybe technology for
crying out loud that you don't need to
have a biological system it's nice to
grow a few fresh vegetables instead of
Adam it'll survive on canned food for
two years yeah but yeah certainly
whether it's tourism is kind of
stretching the point because and these
people will be getting paid to go rather
than paying someone else for the
privilege of going but there's already
been proposals for lunar flyby tourism
at the price price point of about 100
million dollars per seat and so far
there's nobody taking taking them up on
it yeah but that could be done in less
than seven years with existing
technology yeah
we flow yeah sorry didn't act okay I it
was a teleprompter issue um thank you so
much for your time here today you know
the vision of going into space there's
been a great intersection between that
and libertarianism for a long time I
think partially because people do see it
as an arena for sort of new experiments
and living beyond just being as I think
you've known since you're a kid one of
the coolest things a human being could
do and thanks for helping make it
possible and thanks for being here today
with us on the recent TV having me here
thank you